Thanks to Brilliant for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Go to Brilliant.org/microcosmos to get 20%
off an annual premium subscription!
We’re nearing the end of our fourth season
of Journey to the Microcosmos, and over that
time, we’ve been able to see microbes through
all kinds of lenses—literally—thanks to
James, our master of microscopes.
For the rest of us on the Microcosmos team,
it’s been really cool to not only see the
footage that James has recorded, but also
see the journey that he has been on with the
microscopes themselves.
Now, we’ve been able to make this journey
because of all of you and the support you
have shown to this channel by watching and
commenting and sharing with others, or even
and especially by supporting us on Patreon.
We’ve all been on this journey together,
so let’s look back on where it’s taken
us, and also get a peek at where we’re going
in the future.
In the first season, James started out with
two microscopes.
One was a microscope that he assembled himself
from different parts for under $200.
The other microscope was a Motic BA310 that
he received from a microscope company shortly
after we started this channel.
And these microscopes give us so much beautiful
footage, thanks in part to the different techniques
that James used with them, whether that was
bright-field or phase contrast or darkfield,
or some other technique to manipulate the
light shining on the microcosmos.
But these microscopes also had their limits,
so we were really excited to see what would
happen when James bought a new microscope
before the start of our third season: the
Zeiss Axioscope 5.
This new microscope came with higher quality
objectives (which are the lenses on the bottom
of the microscope), as well as prisms that
made it possible for us to look at microbes
with differential interference contrast microscopy,
a technique that sharpened their features
and made them seem more three-dimensional
on our screen.
We have videos exploring these different techniques
and microscopes, so if you want to learn more
about them, we recommend checking those out
because light is much weirder than it seems.
But we wanted to do a quick summary for reasons
that are probably very clear from the title
of this video: we have upgraded our microscope!
The Zeiss Axioscope 5 was a very exciting
change, but it was also an expensive one.
So when James bought it, he was only able
to get two objectives: a 20x objective and
a 63x objective.
Adding that to the 10x magnification the eyepiece
gives, let us magnify our samples by 200x
and 630x respectively, which is not bad.
But a standard microscope usually comes with
5-6 objectives for a reason: the microcosmos
is full of things both small and large to
observe and there isn’t a one-size-fits-all
objective that you can use to observe everything.
So one of James’ priorities was expanding
his set of objectives so that he could have
the flexibility to see the microcosmos at
more scales.
And thanks to his recent upgrade, he’s now
gone from a set of 2 to a set of six that
range from 5x to 100x and that gives us a
magnification range from 50x to 1000x.
Since I have gotten my own prototype of the
microcosmos microscope that we are manufacturing
thanks to backers of our kickstarter, I’ve
been amazed at how important it is to have
this variety of options, and how much time
I spend on the lower magnifications and well
as going deeper .
So without further ado, let’s introduce
these different objectives by looking at a
ciliate called Tetrahymena that’s taken
up residence in a rotifer exoskeleton.
With the 5x objective, we can see little dots
swimming in what used to be empty space, but
it’s hard to make out the details.
When we move to the 10x objective, we can
start to make out shapes of the Tetrahymena
and more of the emptiness around them, but
it’s difficult to see the exoskeleton.
Then as we start to go up in magnification,
the details of the exoskeleton become clearer.
It's cool to see more and more of those details
as we zoom in.
And especially when we get to the 100x objective,
which gives us 1000x magnification, you can
make out so much of the insides of the Tetrahymena,
that they look like bags of very resilient bubbles.
Here’s another ciliate called a Pseudoprorodon
that James looked at through all of these objectives.
At first it just looks like a little green
thing floating around and knocking into stuff.
But as we go up in magnification, we can start
to make out the subtle undulations of its
body, which shifts the different shades of
green.
And as we look even closer, the green itself
takes on a new life, revealing the perimeters
of the individual algae inside the pseudoprorodon.
Revealing those details inside the tetrahymena
and pseudoprorodon comes at a cost.
We can’t see as much of the world around
them, whether that’s the emptiness around
the rotifer exoskeleton or the objects that
the pseudoprorodon keeps bumping into.
Whether or not you need those details depends
on what you’re trying to learn or what we
are trying to show, and that’s why having
the flexibility to look through a wider range
of objectives is such an exciting upgrade
for us.
Objectives are our gateways to the microcosmos,
and we’re excited to have all of these new
scales to look at.
We’ve also made some other upgrades so we
can revisit techniques we used on our older microscopes.
Like a polarizer, because who doesn’t love
this shiny, iridescent stuff?
But we’re not just sticking with what we’ve
known.
Thanks to this upgrade, we’ve got a whole
new way to look at cells: fluorescence microscopy.
And we are so excited for this one.
The techniques we’ve highlighted so far
are all clever manipulations of white light,
a mixture of many visible wavelengths of light.
But in fluorescence microscopy, instead of
illuminating our sample with that mixture,
we choose a specific wavelength of light.
That light is called the excitation light
because, well, it excites certain structures
based on their chemistry.
And those excitable structures then emit some
light of their own.
The emission light will then travel back through
the objective, get past barriers that filter
out the excitation light, and then show up
in our eyes as vivid color.
With our upgrade, we have four different wavelengths
of light that we can use for fluorescence
microscopy, and the parts of the sample that
we see fluoresce will depend on which light we use.
In this footage, we’re looking at the Pseudoprorodon
that we saw earlier, only this time it’s
being hit with 385 nanometer light.
The red we see is the fluorescence from natural
structures, this is called autofluorescence.
The rest of the organism is dark because it
did not respond to that 385 nanometer light,
making the color all the more vibrant.
But the power of fluorescence microscopy is
not just finding fluorescent structures that
exist in nature.
Chemists and biologists have developed all
sorts of ingenious techniques to highlight
different parts of cells using fluorescent
dyes and proteins.
James is working on building up his arsenal
of fluorescence microscopy tools and techniques
so that soon, we’ll be able to dive even
deeper into the microcosmos to seek out things
that have been hidden from us before, uncovering
the unseen world inside the unseen world that
surrounds us
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us and thank you to Brilliant for sponsoring
this episode.
Brilliant features hands-on courses in science,
math and computer science, and there you can
learn everything from Astrophysics to Programming
With Python.
If all of that sounds like a lot to choose
from and you need some help figuring out where
to start, Brilliant has a bunch of curated
Learning Paths where they’ve compiled courses
into categories like “Science Foundations”
and “College Mathematics” so you can make
sure you’re taking all of the courses that
will help you get where you want to go on
your learning journey.
If you’re interested in learning more, you
can get 20% off an annual premium subscription
at Brilliant.org/microcosmos.
The names that you’re seeing on the screen
right now, they are our patrons on Patreon.
And they’re the reasons that we’ve been
able to stay on this journey for so long and
also explore our world in such new and exciting
ways.
We’re so excited to be using the resources
from your patronage to do really cool things
so that we can see deeper into our world.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby